president
ladies and gentlemen hijacking a plane
is piracy with 171 passengers on board
it's kidnapping when these acts are
carried out by a state
it's hostage-taking and state
piracy for what to get hold of
a young journalist and his partner whose
free speech
is intolerable for mr lukashenko
we had to react quickly and strongly
and with it we quickly agreed to adopt
sanctions against the belarusian regime
commensurate with the gravity of the
event
and these include additional individual
sanctions
targeted economic measures and a ban
on belarusian airlines we also called
on european airlines to avoid belarusian
airspace
a recommendation that was immediately
fallout
in the wake of this decision the uk and
the u.s took
similar measures and i would like to
emphasize
three clear messages the first
is for roman potassievich and all
political prisoners
the eu will not rest until
you are released the second is for mr
kashenko mr protestevic
must be released immediately until that
we hold you responsible for his physical
and mental health
and our third message is to the
belarusian people
and especially to those fighting for
democracy
freedom of expression and media freedom
the eu stands by you and will continue
our direct support for your struggle to
choose
your destiny dear colleagues
as we did last year on china we had
a strategy debate on our relationship
with russia
and we were unanimous in condemning
russia's illegal provocative
and disruptive activities but above
all we have given ourselves time
for a high quality debate and i would
like to explain the method
the objectives and the first resolutions
first the method the relationship
between the eu
and russia is complex and every complex
and strategic choice
must be must begin with building
our collective intelligence this takes
time but in the long term it saves time
once we share a common analysis it's
easier
to take a collective decision we are
then stronger because
we are more united and during our
strategic distribution the leaders share
their views
and experience with russia without
reservation
russia has created a string of conflicts
in its neighborhood and beyond
and facing that we have often reacted
rather than act it proactively
rather than reacting to what we do not
want we must first decide
what we do want from russia we need
to better define our strategic
objectives and how best
to achieve them and this must be done
in line in accordance with the five
guiding principles we have already
agreed
the as valid as ever implementation
of the misagreements strengthen
relations with the eastern partners
strengthening the union's resilience
selective cooperation with russia on
issues
of interest to the union and the need
for people-to-people contacts and
support
for russian civil society we will
continue this work
at our next meeting based on a report we
have requested
from the commission and the high
representative and this report
will contain concrete options or
scenarios
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Applause]
president vanderlaan
fun
our immediate focus is of course in all
these meetings on beating covet 19
everywhere and ending the pandemic and
of course
rebuilding our economies and
the dominant topic in all these sessions
we had together the meetings and summits
but also
those who are ahead of us is
vaccines and the equal and fair access
to vaccines globally
this is why mario draghi and i convened
the g20 global health summit
it was on one hand the lessons learned
but on the other hand
also concrete pledges and in their own
declaration the leaders
gave a very strong signal they had three
main points in the g20
rome declaration first of all they
committed to boosting
production capacity in low and middle
income countries and i come back to that
later
then of course the second topic tackling
those bottlenecks in the supply chains
so if you look at the rome declaration
you see it's a player
for seamless flows of vaccines and
components we know that we're not there
yet
but their own declaration was the very
first time that there was this
commitment towards that
and we committed in investing in a
global surveillance
and early warning system knowing that we
failed on that at the beginning
of the pandemic but as i've said in the
short term
the dominant topic is vaccine supply in
low and middle income countries and
there are three strands
we follow up the first one is indeed
kovacs
it's good that we have covax as xiaomi
shell said it was
the european union who was one of the
main founder
of covax up to today
up to three billion euros have been
invested in covax by pledge to covax by
team europe so far
but at the moment being in kovacs not so
much the money is the problem it's more
the access to
to vaccines vaccines in kind and
therefore on top
team europe pledged to donate at least
100 million doses of vaccines by the end
of the year
the second strand is i'm convinced we
have to engage the private sector
more in that topic and at the health
summit
we worked with our industrial partners
and it was good to see that the
industrial partners
committed publicly that they are willing
to deliver 1.3 billion doses of vaccines
till the end of the year
to low and middle-income countries at
non-profit to low-income countries
and at low costs to middle-income
countries so it's good to see that
public announcement we can keep track
and we can make sure with all the
scrutiny that there is
um 1.3 billion doses delivered in these
circumstances
till the end of the year and indeed the
third pillar
is export of vaccines
we cannot just keep the whole production
for ourselves
and europe has proven proven that it is
possible
it is possible to vaccinate your own
people
and to allow for export since
january we have been exporting almost
half of our production
and if you transfer that in numbers out
of 600 million doses of vaccines
produced here in europe until now
around about 300 million doses have been
exported to over 90 countries
and honorable members if all the other
vaccine producers had followed our
example
the world would be a different place
today
and in the course of this discussion of
course the question of the trips
agreement has been raised recently
when the u.s administration put forward
their thoughts
we said we are open for discussions
now just four weeks later we have put
forward a new global trade initiative
at the wto aiming to deliver
more equitable access to vaccines and
therapeutics
and this initiative has three elements
the first is we want clear rules
to keep supply chains open and to
eliminate
export restrictions export restrictions
for vaccines and of
course also for all the components that
are necessary to produce these vaccines
so clear rules in wto to put disciplines
if they are
exports obstacles secondly
we want to help ramp up production not
only in europe
but also in africa or elsewhere where
needed
and for that we need to ensure also in
wto
clear roles to ensure the necessary
transfer
transfer of technologies and know-how in
emergencies and here i want to be very
clear i think intellectual property has
to be product
protected because it is the idea behind
the
breakthrough and it retains the
incentives
for innovation in research and
development
and of course voluntary licenses are the
most effective way to facilitate
expanding production
and at the g20 global health summit in
rome
leaders reaffirmed this assessment
however
and that's the big however in a global
emergency like this like this pandemic
if voluntary licensing fails
compulsory licensing has to be and
is the legitimate tool to scale up
production
and this is why together with wto we
want to clarify and simplify
the use of compulsory licensing in times
of national emergency
and we have discussed this proposal
yesterday and
wto vaccine production requires of
course
a lot of know-how we all know that so
these are very complicated biological
processes
they require no hoe that require
technology they require skilled
personnel
and of course infrastructure and i think
it is not by simply waiving intellectual
property rights that you get there
it is actually by collaboration and if
need be compulsory licensing
that you enhance technology transfer
because the patent is not telling the
whole story a painting
patent is explaining part of the
production process
and get me right it should not stand in
the way so there are also provisions for
that in our proposal in wto
but you need to have more when it comes
to these kinds of complex
products and this is why europe started
this initial initiative in wto
to simplify compulsory licensing
and this is also why europe committed
1 billion euro to create with our
african partners and our industrial
partners so all three
manufacturing hubs in different regions
in africa and
at a certain point in time will
certainly come back to that discussion
the impact
for
[Music]
and this is why now words must be
followed by tangible action across all
sectors of our economies and our
societies
you know that we're going to present the
fit for 55 package
in mid-july and i'm glad that at the
special meeting
of the european council at the end of
may heads of state and government in the
first
discussion of the overall package showed
broad support
because europe wants to lead the way in
this transition towards an economy
that gives more to the planet than it
takes away
now we want to broker the same ambition
at global level clear commitments
followed by equally clear action
in particular in alignment with the g7
and the united states in the g7
would be very welcome and it's time to
do that now
and with the us we will not only grow
our common trade and investment
relationship in support of the green and
the digital transition of our economies
together we will also engage with our
international partners for shared
commitment and joint action
to reduce emissions by 2030 and to have
tangible goals to become climate neutral
economies
by 2050. and in this way
we hope and we work for achieving the
most ambitious
possible outcome at cop26 in glasgow
and at the biodiversity cup 15 in
kunming
honourable members this is the ambition
we want to bring to the table
when we meet with our partners and
friends from all over the world
i know that you the european parliament
share
this ambition because we all want to end
this pandemic
and we all want to leave a healthy
planet
to future generations long-lived europe
thank you